hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the speed chase Championship 2023 now
the match is over I've watched the
entire thing some three and a half hours
it was incredibly enjoyable so while I
am going to present a couple of games
you guys should watch the entire thing
if if you can manage the time because it
is a very thrilling and you will have an
excellent time especially if you don't
know who won which I will of course
reveal uh after uh I I show you the game
so this is the first game that we are
going to cover uh it's from the five
plus one Blitz section as you know
speeches Championship consists of three
parts first they have the five plus one
section then the three plus one section
and then the one plus one section uh
long long time ago was actually five
plus two so now you have to be a little
bit faster so it's Magnus Carlson versus
Hikaru Nakamura uh I I don't think I got
the ratings right that this is a rating
from the first game but as the ratings
change every game I didn't change it for
for like the second game and uh so far
in the finals of the speeches
Championship Magnus has won two times
against Karu and Hikaru has won one time
against Magnus so Magnus is leading with
a one point margin and if he car wins he
equalizes their head-to-head score if
Magnus wins then he's gonna be three to
one in magnus's favor so let's check it
out this is one of the uh for the first
game that we are going to show from the
five plus one section uh Magnus had the
white pieces and he opened with E4 we
have E5 by Hikaru Knight F3 Knight to C6
and Magnus goes for the uruil Lopez with
Bishop to B5 Knight F6 he Cargoes for
the uh Berlin defense we have D3 Bishop
to C5 and now uh the the very particular
move now uh C3 uh Bishop captures and C6
and castles are are the top three moves
but Bishop to A4 is incredibly rare and
one of the people that actually played
it before is Magnus Carlsen himself he
played it in a World Chess Championship
in the world rapid
championship against Dimitri and reikin
and he won that game so let's see how
how Hikaru continues and they can Castle
here but Hikaru goes for Pawn the D6 we
have Castles by both of them and now we
have Pawn to C3 and there is a game
where A5 was played but here Hikaru
plays H6 and it is now as of move 7 then
we have a completely new game so H3 of
course stopping Bishop to G4 and Bishop
to B6 we have Knight beta D2 Pawn to A6
and now Rook to E1 so all very standard
stuff here uh Bishop back to A7 and now
Knight to F1 the Knight is coming to G3
of course uh we have Knight to E7 and
now Pawn to D4 Magnus strikes in the
center Knights the G6 and Knight to G3
so the knights nicely oppose each other
Pawn to B5 chases away the bishop Bishop
the C2 and now Pawn to C5 so the usual
early lopezian moves we have Pawn to A4
and now Bishop to B7 hikaru's Bishop
bear is excellently placed here eyeing
magnus's King uh Bishop to E3 and now
Pawn to B4 uh we have pawned a five
magnets grabs more space on the queen
side B captures and c3b capture C
capture C captures and best ship the C6
now
later on you can put the bishop to B5 if
if needed so here we have Queen to D2
Magnus connects the Rooks against the
queen into the game and here the only
real attempt for hikar because this is a
very dangerous position for him to be in
is uh King to H7 but this will only be
revealed why after we show the next move
Hikaru actually played rook d8 and
Magnus accepted the challenge he played
Bishop captures on H6 and Okay g
captures with Queen captures and H6 now
hoping to get some sort of a checkmating
attack with Knight F5 and queen to G7
Checkmate sohikaru has to play Queen to
E7 he has to bring the queen to f8 to
stop Checkmate and now comes Bishop to
B3 already with a very nasty threat of
Simply Queen captures and G6 as the F
Pawn is now pinned so Hikaru blocks the
diagonal he plays Pawn to D5 and now
Magnus plays D captures on E5 which is
uh here you you actually have a lot of
moves to consider from I'm just going to
show you a really fun move which is
Knight captures and E5 and now the
problem is if the Knight is captured
then you play Knight F5 and now how do
you stop Checkmate okay we play Queen to
fade but now this Knight is no longer
defended Queen captures now uh the
Knight is still hanging if the Knight
moves the bishop hangs and if you play
something like Rook to E6 the try and uh
defend everything then Queen to G5 check
and after Rook G6 now comes Knight to E7
check with a beautiful Monster Fork here
King H7 now we're gonna play Queen
captures on E5 and black is completely
busted so what you would have to do
after this Knight captures an E5 move is
Queen to f8 right away and then we sort
of trade everything Queen captures an f8
King captures an f8 Knight captures and
c6d captures on e4 and now Knight to F5
uh with Magnus having a much much better
position objectively winning uh would he
win it to that uh a different story but
he went for a different idea he did not
go for Knight captures and E5 he played
the D captures on E5 and now how do you
continue here do you move the knight uh
well you kind of have to but also you
could capture on E5 Hikaru captures on
E5 Knight to D7 for example if you just
move the Knight Knight to G5 is Just
Deadly there's no stopping this so the
Knight can't really move
uh Knight captures 95 was played and now
Knight to F5 threatening mate in one so
Hikaru has to stop it but how do you
stop it now uh Queen to f8 doesn't
really work here you're just gonna play
Queen G5 check and after the Knight
blocks You're Gonna Play Queen captures
on F6 and now I have to Rook the E6
You're Gonna Play Queen back to G5 and
after let's say queen 38 offering a
queen trade now Queen H5 and again
Knight to G5 Queen H7 are coming queen
to F6 You're Gonna Play Knights to G5
and now Queen to h8 offering a queen
trade but not even a nice night stage
six check nicely connects with the F7
pawn and that's it King G7 Knight is
gonna capture on F7 the queen is now
hanging after the queen moves You're
Gonna Play e captures on D5 now attack
the bishop and the rook and after you
trade okay uh black is still sort of in
the game but of course black will get
checkmated very soon
uh so after this Knight to F5 move
Hikaru did not defend with Queen to f8
he actually played Bishop captures on F2
which is a great move if Magnus accepts
now you could actually take the take the
bishop and allow the uh the knights e to
G4 check move which Forks the your king
and the Queen and after age captures the
other Knight now Forks your king and the
queen king G3 Knight captures an H6
Knight captures an E7 with Czech Rook
captures and E captures on D5 uh Rook
captures anyone Rook captures another
Bishop to D7 okay you're up a pawn uh
clearly you have a better position but
you would still have to grind a lot but
of course there's no reason to do this
after Bishop captures an F2 Magnus just
move the king king to H1 and now Queen
to f8 Hikaru has to defend against
Checkmate now Queen captures an F6 Rook
to E6 and now comes Queen to G5 with
check Knight blocks with Knight to G6
and here Magnus played a rook to F1 and
he was in this position on move 29 that
Hikaru Nakamura resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here it
seems like okay okay maybe the position
is still very rich a lot to do but not
really this is a thread he captures on
D5 which will win material this is a
threat that will win material so
basically whatever you do let's say
Bishop to A7 just e captures and D5 and
even if you play something like Rook 88
D captures and C6 already gives you a
beautiful pass Pawn here but even that
doesn't matter like let's say King H7
you try to get into the game a little
bit as long as your king is here this
threat has been reintroduced now that
the pawn captured on C6 and The Bishop's
diagonal has been freed you have to
defend against that but now let's say
queen H5 checking the Jade Queen
captures on G6 and you get checkmated uh
King dh8 You're Gonna Play Queen to F6
with checking to H7 Knights the G5 with
checking to G8 now again Queen G6 check
and you have to either put the queen
here or you play King the h8 and then
Queen to H7 will be Checkmate so of
course he covered did not allow this
after Rook to F1 he resigned and a very
nice victory for Magnus in the five plus
one section now the five plus one
section ended by Magnus only winning by
a one point margin but then Hikaru
really uh got on a roll he he had like a
a four point lead in the three plus one
section but then Magnus sort of woke up
and he minimized the damage so Magnus
won the five plus one section with one
one point margin then Hikaru retaliated
by winning the uh three plus one section
with a one point margin and now all
that's left is the bullet and we are
going to show the final game of the
bullet section the most requested one as
it really uh you know how everyone is
always bragging okay this is like a 98.1
accuracy game this is like a 99 accuracy
game this is like a 97.8 accuracy game
well this is nothing like that this is
like 85 uh Point accuracy game or
something like that uh so a lot a lot of
stuff has been missed here but as you
would expect from a bullet game so let's
check it out Magnus again has the white
pieces he's leading the match by one
point so Hikaru needs a win here to
force tie break so let's see what
happened E4 by Magnus we have a
repetition from the game we just saw
Knight of three Knight to C6 and now
Knight the C3 Magnus mixes it up with
the three Knights opening and Hikaru
counters it with the steinies defense G6
to the three Knights opening with Pawn
to D4 Magnus strikes in the center we
have characters captors and Bishop to G7
it's okay nothing new here Bishop T3
Knight G37 Knight to F6 is a bit more
popular Knight D7 uh a bit more flexible
you have support for D5 and F5 from that
night Queen to D2 Magnus announces a
queen side castling um a plant Ponte D6
and queen side castles and there are
some games where castles and Bishop T6
were played but here Hikaru plays Pawn
to H6 and it is now as of move 8 that we
have a completely new game so Bishop to
E2 with Bishop to E6 and now Rook H the
E1 nicely putting the roxa in the center
of the board Queen the D7 Hikaru also
announces a queen side castle and Magnus
rates here once we have captors captures
and now Knights the D5 Magnus says all
right I'm gonna have a beautiful night
on D5 or you know you can just give up
the bishop pair so Hikaru wants to
preserve the bishop pair as magnus's
King has Castle queenside and his Bishop
pair is nicely uh that's a weird Arrow
eyeing that white king so upon the A6 we
have Pawn to F4 we have Queen side
Castles by Hikaru and the bishop to F3
we have came to B8 King to B1 a nice
prophylactic moves by both of them and
The Rook H the E8 we have Bishop to F2
Magnus now planning to go for Bishop to
H4 which will attack The Rook but really
he's going for Bishop to H4 and Knight
to F6 which will force the bishop to
capture the Knight and he will win one
of the Bishops so rock the C8 by Hikaru
Bishop to H4 and now Knight to D4 Hikaru
has a plan of his own on how to
eliminate magnus's Bishop pair uh Knight
to F6 attacks the rook and the Queen and
now Hikaru has to trade Bishop captures
an F6 Bishop captures and Knight
captures on F3
uh G captures this sort of messes up a
magnus's spawn structure on the king
said but it also strengthens his center
now his E4 Pawn is is a much stronger uh
and also you are defended against any
Bishop to G4 ideas so Bishop capture
Sunny to check uh Magnus sort of missed
this move because now if um Magnus
captures an A2 then Queen the E6 check
will pick up the bishop here on on F6 so
King to C1 and now Bishop back to E6 so
here Hikaru is in a great position he's
up a pawn in a game that he absolutely
has to win so okay Magnus plays H4 Queen
to B5 now uh we have Queen to D3 Magnus
offers a queen trade it's a bishops of
opposite color so Magnus is confident
that he will be able to draw this and
win the match so Hikaru has the decline
Queen A5 with a very nice control here
over uh the the white King's uh Castle
so to say uh Queen to C3 Magnus offers
the queen trade again and again Hikaru
declines Queen A1 check doesn't really
do anything King to D2 and you're very
safe there so Queen to H5 and now Pawn
to B3 with King the A8 and now King to
B2 we have Queen back to B5 Hikaru
looking for ways to create some threads
here and now uh he found one that is A5
A4 he wants to weak and the white uh the
white king side this way and Magnus
plays H5 his idea is okay I'm either
gonna mess up his correspond structure
or if he captures with the queen I'm
gonna play Rook to H1 and then pick up
the H6 Pawn so you have to play this or
you have to go for an allowed attack
with D5 Hikaru decides to go Queen
captures on H5 Rook to H1 and now Queen
back to B5 we have real characters on H6
Ponte A5 now Hikaru starts his attack on
the queen side and Rook to G1 now
uh we have Pawn to B6 uh you have to
defend the A5 Pawn the Magnus is a
threat with Rook to G1 with a rook to G5
attacks the queen and once the queen
moves you just capture the A5 Pawn so
the B6 uh Pawn now defends the A5 Pawn
so okay Rook to G5 still planta C5 and
now Rook back to H2 now you have to find
the different uh entrance into hikaru's
position Ponte A4
[Music]
about that uh
sorry about that it was a very important
phone call uh A4 and now of course he
wants the bus to open the position with
the bishop Queen and pawn attacking that
B3 Pawn so Rook to D2 uh and now a
captures and B3 C characters and King to
B7 now Hikaru getting ready to put the
Rook on the a file and he is very very
close to equalizing the match and the
winning and forcing tie breaks in in
hopes to win the the entire thing so
Magnus plays Rook captures on D6 he car
willingly gave up the spawn and now Rook
to A8 we have Ponte F5 and this is where
things get incredibly interesting now uh
bear in mind that this is a bullet game
and of course you don't have all the
time in the world upon run your ideas
but uh Hikaru should definitely capture
this because it's a free pawn and Magnus
doesn't the the F5 move doesn't really
do anything point being that if you
capture that the bishop can never uh and
now the e-file has opened up and once
the bishop captures on B3 it's game over
there's no move for white now for
example if Queen captures Now The Rook
gets into the game rookie do checking
after King to C3 like maybe rookie 3
check wins the queen doesn't really
matter you're gonna get checkmated very
soon but Magnus strictly Hikaru played
Queen to F1 with some Queen to A1 action
in stored but now F captures an E6 and
Hikaru still is much better if he plays
Queen to A1 check but he didn't if Queen
A1 check King to C2 he can play Rook the
A2 with check and now okay the problem
is uh here it doesn't matter that you
win the queen after Queen to B2 you
can't just take the queen because the
this Pawn if it becomes a pass Pawn
becomes too dangerous you have to play F
captures on E6 and that's what Hikaru
had to see in order to actually find
this and I have to Rook D7 checking to
C8 attacking The Rook The Rook goes back
attacks the queen and now you trade the
Rogue captures with check Bishop
captures and you move the queen and okay
black is winning but this is bullet uh
we had rooked A1 now threatening all
sorts of checkmates well like Queen to
B1 but now magnus's position is
completely winning and there are various
ways to do so you could play Rook to D7
check you could play Rook captures on B6
check Magnus actually played neither of
those moves which is very interesting
I'm just gonna show Rook capture some B6
because it's devastating King characters
on B6 Queen captures on C5 as The Rook
also guards there King to B7 and now
Queen to D5 check and now the Queen
Bishop combo is absolutely deadly King
to B8 Bishop to E5 with the check King
to A7 now Queen to D7 with check you
pick up the rook and then of course with
Bishop Queen and Rook you can easily
Checkmate the black king king will move
you're gonna of course capture The Rook
with check Bishop B5 checking goes to
the back rank you eliminate The Rook
King here Queen D7 tracking B8 Bishop E5
checking eight Queen to C8 King A7 and
of course Bishop D4 with a beautiful
Bishop Queen uh uh sort of a crossover
Checkmate so after Rook day one Magnus
didn't go for this check he didn't go
for this check he actually played Queen
see to stopping any checks from Hikaru
and now Hikaru is again winning with
Rook to 80 check but he doesn't find it
of course the idea is that now you win
the White Queen and if King captures you
just uh sorry you just Checkmate the
white King on the movies King to B2 and
then Queen to A1 will be Checkmate the
C2 yeah the C2 and B3 squares are
covered so after Queen to C2 uh Hikaru
played uh he doubled up on the a file
but now it's Magnus again who is winning
and I'm sure you guys know why and that
is Rook captures and sorry Rook captures
and B6 Magnus did not play it he played
Rook to D7 check which is also winning
uh King to C6 and now Magnus finally
goes for a double Rook sacrifice uh and
he finds it this way Rook captures on C5
with check B captors and Rook the C7
check this allows the queen into the
game and the Queen Bishop combo is now
absolutely deadly King captures on C7
Queen captures and C5 with checking the
B7 and now Queen to D5 with check
forcing the king to a dark Square we
King to B8 or you could go to King to
see it but doesn't matter then Queen to
D7 check will again Force the king to a
dark Square stalking to be a bishop to
E5 with the check and he was in this
position and move 44 that Hikaru and
Magnus agreed to a drawn as okay it's a
first Checkmate but Magnus doesn't need
to force it as a draw also wins him the
match sohikaru agreed um uh to a draw
here now as Magnus uh went into this
game with a one point lead Hikaru
absolutely needed to win the full point
in order to equalize but as the game was
run it is Magnus who wins the 2023 speed
Chess Championship and now he won the
finals three times uh hikar won it
against Magnus uh once so that's uh very
nice for Magnus and this Magnus said he
definitely has bragging rights now but
it was a really incredible match uh
one's a three plus one section started
because Magnus was absolutely destroying
everyone in the three plus one section
it was uh it was inhuman to watch that
and Hikaru uh they completely destroyed
him then Magnus somehow recovered and he
won like three or four games in a row to
minimize the damage these are the
basically the standings of all the time
formats so in five plus five plus one
Nakamura uh lost the Magnus with uh with
a one point margin uh then he covered
defeated Magnus with also with a five to
four but he was leading like five to
zero or something like that and then in
the OnePlus One section of course it was
3.5 four and a half so Magnus basically
wins the entire thing uh with with a one
point margin so how you end this of
course we've already shown it King day
seven Bishop to D4 check King to B8 you
bring the queen into the game Queen to
d8 checking the B7 and now Queen to D7
check we have to force the king to a
dark Square King Day six now Queen to C6
check King to A5 and not Bishop the C3
would be a similar but a very different
uh uh Bishop Queen Checkmate so after
Bishop D5 Hikaru resigned and the Magnus
wins it all he's the 2023 speed Chess
Championship champion and there you have
it uh very nicely done by Magnus
defeating everyone it was very close
against the car but it always is as
Hikaru is just that kind of a player the
the lower the the time gets the the more
dangerous the car is and someone even
said like before when it was five plus
two three plus two it was
um sort of a bigger Advantage for Magnus
because the more time you give Magnus is
he is the most accurate player the
stronger he will get and now when it's a
five plus one three plus one one plus
one of course it will be easier for
players to play against Magnus uh it
will be very interested if they did sort
of a test with five plus zero three plus
zero and one plus zero uh but I don't
know if they will ever do that it would
be fun though
uh so uh that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed this very nicely very very
nicely done I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Carlos Carla and I
would like to thank Paul Miller Kenneth
Frazier Ludy and Ralph and Nick met in
Yasser for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
probably the next video is coming from
the world junior Championship see you
soon